the big parade received a photo player
Medal of Honor I'm sure
it is such an amazing experience the
people who had gone through the war
would have recognized a great deal as
being just as they remembered it and the
people who didn't suddenly realize what
their husbands and sons were talking
about so it had also the feeling of
being against war in the future which
was very unusual for an American film
and cinematically
it's beyond praise the big parade is
still relevant because it is the first
world war made by the men who fought it
and it it's also extremely entertaining
and it's it sets the one slightly
unfortunate thing I think it's
responsible for all those service
comedies that followed it they it it was
so successful people realized they could
make endless films about soldiers and
sailors and get away with them falling
over each other and to merit a grade
point but that picture also stars john
gilbert in one of the finest
performances that the silent film ever
captured I was always intrigued King
Vidor tell me that among his advisors
was William Wellman they direct his
fellow director and Wellman said that
the German aircraft used to come up
behind a squadron of troops marching
along and skim their helmets with the
undercarriage with the wheels and they
actually staged that for the picture